if you guys were actually Pokemon
trainers in real life what would your
Pokemon started be if you could add any
of the 809 or 14 or Totodile would be my
pokemon from generation to start pokemon
pokemon gold there it is he already had
that one do you have to pick a starter
Pokemon any one of my problems would be
signed up nice great camaraderie yeah
yeah nice nicely done
you'd both get a bunch of action scenes
in this movie that I mean they were
great fun but at the same time they're
always involving like CG Pokemon at the
same time so what was that like for you
guys to shoot those scenes and how cool
was it for you to see the fly not
realize hang on the big screen it was
kind of difficult because you know
something that's not there but Rob made
us feel really comfortable he made sure
that we knew exactly what was happening
in the scene at all times were the
Pokemon were their eyeline what they
were doing so that way we didn't feel
like we were lost and like weird is like
[Music]
basically just what was it like to
finally see that that fully realized
scene all amazed I mean incredible yeah
it's good the first question I loved
doing our stunts and I loved I mean I
loved I got to carry side up the entire
time and they made him you know the real
weight so it was realistic but it was
difficult but we got to use our
imagination and go back to like being a
kid again and so to see it come to
fruition was mind-blowing it was more
than I could have ever imagined as a kid
yeah it was really well done it's like
your childhood dream come true or do you
like to have to be your best yeah it's a
lot of fun speaking of that if you get a
chance to do a sequel is there anything
you guys would like to see for your
characters and maybe rather than having
to carry around your Pokemon maybe to
get them a little scooter or something
really cool like in real life
wait no I want to be putting without
that really but yours your character
yeah I really care yeah yeah what's your
favorite Pokemon just from this movie
because it's kind of a new world it's a
new kind of interpret
so what's your favorite one without
revealing sure yeah anything so out of
the ones that have already been revealed
risk me to the question okay then I'm
gonna say magic harp I thought blows my
mind it's a good say yeah I like I said
like Jigglypuff I want to see dude if
there is a sequel to I want to see like
Julie put somebody to sleep well they do
that's a sequel spoiler for the night
thank you guys so much I have to head
out for today hey I appreciate it
imbecile